quand le bâtiment va tout va une formule
du 19e siècle qui ne serait plus à
l'ordre du jour à la Fédération
française du bâtiment en Indre-et-Loire
tenait hier soir son assemblée générale
et elle tire la sonnette d'alarme selon
elle les conséquences des annonces
gouvernementales du 5 juin pourrait être
catastrophique sur l'emploi du secteur
on en parle avec notre invité du jour
Stéphane pouessel bonjour bonjour vous
êtes donc le président de la Fédération
française du bâtiment en Indre-et-Loire
première des nouveautés le prêt à taux
zéro qui permettait donc au foyer
modeste d'acheter leur premier logement
a été reconduit jusqu'en 2027 mais dans
des conditions d'attribution différentes
impossible désormais d'avoir accès au
PTZ pour faire une pour faire construire
une maison neuve et ça ça aura des
conséquences sur votre
secteurs sur notre secteur et ça aura
des conséquences sur nos concitoyens la
première conséquence 35000 communes de
France pouvaient bénéficier de de la CAP
quantité de faire bénéficier le prêt à
taux zéro alors à nos concitoyens il en
restera plus que 1000 donc on a plus la
capacité sur la maison individuelle de
bénéficier du prêt à taux zéro on a plus
que la capacité sur le logement
collectif en zone tendue donc il faut se
rapprocher des métropoles on va de
nouveau désertifier nos campagnes autre
annonce la fin du dispositif Pinel au 31
décembre 2024 ce dispositif incitait les
investisseurs à mettre leur logement
neuf en location contre une réduction
d'impôts ça veut dire qu'en 2025 il y
aura plus aucun dispositif de
défiscalisation et donc peut-être moins
de j'allais dire moins de construction
neuve alors le dispositif Pinel était
annoncé à une fin 2024 on a toujours eu
des dispositifs de soutien à la
construction au logement mais il se
succédaient les uns les autres et
aujourd'hui ça s'arrête du flow cellier
de Rollin voilà le Duflot le Duflot
avait été catastrophique le Pinel avait
rectifié le tir on avait mis deux à s'en
remettre pour rectifier le tir et
revenir au niveau d'avant le Duflot au
niveau du nombre de construction
aujourd'hui avec le Pinel qui va
s'arrêter on avait souhaité on avait été
entendu partiellement lors des 24 heures
du bâtiment le président de la
République avait reçu notre président
national en disant de nouvelles un
nouveau dispositif qui ce qui était le
statut du bailleur privé statut bailleur
privé c'est une une capacité à pouvoir
investir et pas être sans arrêt retenu
par le projet de loi de finances de tous
les années donc ça voulait dire tout
simplement qu'on était en capacité à
investir comme dans une industrie et
puis en amortissait et là on aura plus
rien du tout ce qui fait que les gens
construisaient une un ou deux logements
dans le cadre du Pinel pour pouvoir
faire leur retraite quand il y aura plus
ce dispositif là l'argent qui mettait
dans la construction pour pouvoir faire
leur retraite plus tard ils font la
mettre dans des fonds de pension
et ça c'est pas dans votre intérêt c'est
pas dans notre intérêt c'est pas dans
l'intérêt des Français c'est pas dans
l'intérêt de la création d'emplois ou de
le maintien de l'emploi les dispositifs
annoncés par la première ministre le 5
juin nous laisse penser qu'on va perdre
200 à 300 000 emplois France entière
c'est-à-dire entre 2000 et 3000 emplois
en Touraine
la on n'a jamais aussi peu construit que
dans les dernières années j'ai trouvé
quelques chiffres 330 000 constructions
neuves cette année contre 490000 débuts
des années 2000 comment ça se fait
pourquoi est-ce qu'on construit si peu
en ce moment parce qu'on n'a pas de
volonté politique et puis parce que le
le bâtiment la construction le logement
il y a depuis 6 ans on fait courir un
bruit que c'est une bulle immobilière
qui va éclater un moment donné alors que
nos concitoyens ont besoin d'être logés
l'Union Sociale de l'habitat par exemple
le précise il y a 13000 17000 logements
en demande par nos concitoyens sur la
Touraine 17000 demandes qui ne sont pas
satisfaites aujourd'hui donc 17000
personnes qui se logent 17000 personnes
qui restent dans leur famille qui reste
chez les parents qui se mettent chez les
grands-parents qui peuvent pas
construire qui peuvent pas construire un
projet familial et puis quand on a pas
suffisamment de rotation dans le
logement social c'est-à-dire que si ils
peuvent pas sortir du logement social
parce qu'il y a pas de logement
intermédiaire et bien il y a pas de
place qui se libère donc c'est une
chaîne sans fin si on construit pas de
logement neufs si on ne réhabilite pas
suffisamment les logements anciens et
bien on n'a pas une une
rotation qui se fait sur les logements
et on se retrouve avec une activité qui
va être en berne et surtout le plus
important me semble-t-il c'est une perte
d'emploi et nos concitoyens qui pourront
pas être logés
qu'avez-vous fait pour alerter les
pouvoirs publics le gouvernement pour
qu'ils prennent conscience que selon
vous il va droit dans le mur dès le 5
juin le président de la Fédération
française du bâtiment national l'Union
l'AFPI ont écrit une lettre ouverte au
président de la République lui demandant
de réviser sa copie nous on avait
participé au CNR logement on a fait le
Conseil national de la refondation le
Conseil national
où on avait effectivement fait 19
propositions aucune n'a été retenue 19
contre propositions complètement
catastrophique donc aujourd'hui on va se
mobiliser puisqu'on attend plus rien du
gouvernement on va se mobiliser vers nos
députés vers nos sénateurs c'est les
élus du peuple directement ou par les
grands électeurs à eux de prendre leur
responsabilités